I was hoping you were home ok Audrey you
really freaked us out in descendants 3
we know you lost your shot at the crown
not to mention your boyfriend but don't
worry you don't have to be the queen of
mean to get what you want do you think
we speak for everyone when we say we're
glad you put down that scepter but we
have to be honest
you're evil look was a wicked cool
before you judge Audrey there are some
things you need to know about her she's
not your typical villain kid she's a
good princess gone bad
gone good again but here's what nobody
realizes about Audrey in descendants 3
keep watching to find out who she's
teaming up with after d3 Audrey didn't
start out as evil sure she was a little
full of herself and yes she thought Ben
was her property we're not even sure she
loved Ben or if she was dating him so
she could just wool auradon
I was princess girlfriend on the fast
track to becoming his wife in the Queen
Audrey was clearly better about Mouse
stealing everything she ever wanted but
she shocked everyone when she stole
Maleficent sceptre and turned into the
queen of mean how did this happen let's
start at the beginning and piece this
thing together at the beginning of the
movie Audrey wasn't planning on creating
a sleep spell that knocked out all the
word on she had just returned from the
salon rested and fresh with a fabulous
new makeover you could see the look of
complete and total shock on her face
when Ben proposed - mal we watched
Audrey's dream of being the queen of
auradon shatter like a glass slipper
when Audrey broke into the museum she
didn't intend to go full evil she just
wanted to steal the crown did you notice
that she didn't even put the crown on
her head until after she transformed
into evil Audrey she was about to throw
it away
but then the scepter hypnotized her the
same way Maleficent hypnotized Sleeping
Beauty some people thought that Audrey
caused the guard at the front of the
museum to fall asleep but what if it was
the scepter well if it's in scepter
beckoned Audrey into the museum and
lured her into going full
the scepter wanted her to take control
of it the magic in that staff was too
much for Audrey to resist
she was under an evil spell which caused
her to cast many additional evil curses
so was it all Audrey's fault
keep watching to find out when Ben and
mal got engaged Audrey didn't only lose
out on the crown she also lost her first
love then was the only boy she's ever
had eyes for she had her future with him
all planned out
we know that mal didn't mean to do it
but she took it all away from Audrey
it seemed that Audrey had everything a
princess could one but did she truly
love Ben Audrey was betrothed to Ben
since she was just a little girl perhaps
her grandmother convinced her to love
Ben despite what she really wanted in
Audrey's room there are pictures of her
and then going all the way back to
preschool Audrey was too young to be
able to choose a partner for herself
back then those photos were staged by
Audrey's grandmother who knows if Audrey
would have chosen Ben to be her
boyfriend if she had a choice from the
beginning so who would she choose if it
were up to her we'll get into that a
little bit later it's obvious that
Audrey only wants to make her
grandmother proud in fact every action
Audrey takes in The Descendants movies
is tied to her need to please her Grammy
so when Audrey hears her grandmother's
fighting words of disapproval after mal
and Ben's engagement it cuts her to her
core all she ever wanted was to make her
granny proud our family's status gone
Queen Leah's expectations of Audrey were
impossible to achieve
Audrey reached her breaking point when
she learned she would never be the queen
of auradon
that's when she crowned herself the
queen of mean underneath all of that
pink hair and distressed leather was
just a little girl who needed the
unconditional love and approval of her
grandmother instead her grandmother
slapped her with that cruel comment that
Audrey's mother could hold on to a
prince in her sleep now we see where
Audrey learned to be so mean now here's
the really mind-blowing thing that
nobody gets about Audrey if it wasn't
for her the barrier would have never
been opened
Audrey's evil deeds became the catalyst
for change in auradon
allow us to explain before Audrey stole
the crown and the scepter
their villain was stirring up trouble
that's right we're talking about Hades
after he pushed his way through the
barrier and almost stole all of Mel's
powers everyone in auradon was terrified
they wanted to close the barrier for
good and it was all Mao's idea which was
a total woh moment for fans I think that
we have to close the barrier forever
if Audrey hadn't stolen the crown and
sceptre put asleep and stones fell on
everyone and turned Ben into a beast
Mao would have learned nothing instead
mal came to realize that there is both
good and evil in everyone that
realization is what made mal decide to
take down the barrier for good
so thanks Audrey thankfully when Audrey
woke from her deep sleep she was back to
her old self again alas she was still
without a prince on her arm but don't
feel bad for her
from the sparks flying between Audrey
and Harry we think the pirate's life
might be right for Audrey so what's your
verdict is Audrey mean or misunderstood
sound off in the comments thanks for
watching the things don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos like this one we'll
see you next time
[Music]